hello looking back to gang spots
overwatch hero guys we are rounding it
Irish with the last of the heroes we
have not covered it's been a while since
we talked about a sniper Widowmaker
probably the easiest one to get a hold
of Abba Hanzo Mike McCarty a little bit
trickier yeah Hanzo you really need to
be precise and that's because his arrows
have a lot of travel time his bow and
arrow being the weapon of choice for him
he does have a lot of abilities that are
a little bit underrated until you
realize how you can use them and how you
can support your team from a distance
but he's a really versatile character
and I love playing him let's talk about
that storm blow right off how does that
thing work kind of got a little bit of a
pullback almost like Widowmaker sniper
you kind of need want to make sure it's
fully powered before you launch it off
right yeah if you want to round the
corner and be ready to kill someone
you're gonna have to have it charged
right before you do so there is travel
time in the arrows which is a little bit
tougher to get used to because the you
know they're not going to strike right
away like widow-makers bullets but it's
also on the receiving end harder to
judge when they're gonna land so you can
kind of shoot down a sight line down a
narrow choke point and people might
think you know it's past but then they
pop out and get hit right in the face
for sure he's also got a pretty good
recon ability like Widowmaker actually
and not as good of a wallhack as as she
has but the sonic arrow a probably one
of the most underrated abilities you
reckon definitely because the teammates
can see these people too as I can with
widow-makers ultimate but this only
shows teammates in this limited sphere
but it's really useful especially for
Hanzo because you can see when someone's
going to round a corner so you can have
the arrow already in the air before they
pop out and you can also see where
people are you know to use more powerful
attacks you're gonna use his dragon
strike ultimate or if you're gonna you
know if McCree is gonna get used to get
ready for Deadeye it's a really good
pairing for a lot of powerful attacks I
feel like it's one that when you first
pick up Hanzo you kind of forget to use
a lash like you're like oh god yeah
that's cool down a while ago so make
sure you're always keeping an eye on
those cooldowns folks and then the other
one he's got scatter arrow I find this
one interesting so you can probably help
me with this I'm not really ever sure
when to use this cuz it hits a wall at
first set into loads of different things
I've used it before it's like take down
enemies at a rounded corners you've got
low health
but should I also just be like it's just
shooting this directly at bigger enemies
yeah if you shoot it directly a bigger
enemies it'll do more damage ideally you
want to shoot it in tight spaces where
there's a few people because if you get
two or three people in a stairwell even
if their tanks you might not kill those
tanks but you're gonna do a lot of
damage to people and there's less room
for the arrows to ricochet into the sky
it's also a good last resort if
someone's coming up on you like a McCree
or
tracer shoot it right at their feet and
you can hit them with all eight that has
scatters into it'll kill them
immediately good stuff and Widowmaker
again able to get into like very high
level at high ridges and one not using
for a little hook there and Hans that
doesn't have that but he is able to sort
of mantle off Falls this is another one
like Lucille's where I feel like people
sort of underutilize it when should you
be using this can you use it to like
flank people or is it mostly to get into
like high positions you can use it to
flank people but yeah it's ideal for
getting into the those sniper perches
that he's really good at and where he
thrives above the rest of the team
they're also good for just getting to
the objective I mean you don't have to
turn around corners to go upstairs you
could just run up the side and then run
up the next wall you don't run it like
Genji but you can at least over them
pretty fast but it's also yeah it's good
for finding those elevated positions
where you can cover the rest of your
team and maybe see where someone's gonna
come around and flank your front line
characters his dragons strike it's a
crazy big wall hacking dragon twin
situation when should you utilize this
because when it hits people man it's
powerful yeah you want to really make
sure you line it up that's where the
sonic arrow comes in just fire the sonic
arrow my favorite time to use the dragon
strike is around a payload because you
just fire it straight at the front of
the payload and you see up on the
counter at the top that there are three
people pushing the payload you know
you're gonna hit them because they're by
definition right next to it so it's
straight at the front and it's got a
very net narrow path that it travels but
if you line it up you can go through
however many walls you want for a
certain distance a key thing to remember
is that the dragons don't actually start
until the point of impact so I shoot it
from a long way away make sure the arrow
lands close to the people and it's lined
up because if they can sidestep it the
DPS on it is not crazy high but if they
get stuck somewhere in it where they
can't escape it it's gonna kill them in
two or three seconds yeah that's why
it's especially good at tanks and people
don't usually move that fast I mean some
of them that it can get away from it so
quick Farah for instance all she has to
do is hit shift and I guess the counter
to your argument of like saying hit it
far as I got also don't hit it too
shallow because if we do that then
you're giving them so much time to get
out of the way the key here surprised
because my favorite thing to do is to
see a Reinhardt see four people hind I'm
just launcher ready to shield and they
won't see it coming and it's really all
about kind of getting the drop on them
that's where the elevated positions you
might not actually want to be elevated
for this because you want to make sure
that the Dragons travel a path straight
through as many people on their team as
possible but other than that just
combine it with the sonic arrow any
chance you get last point on Hanzo a
couple of folks you should stay away
from I'm guessing Genji in the back your
brother probably causing a lot of
trouble
yeah any of the offensive characters are
pretty tough to handle especially tracer
because he's got such a precise weapon
and that by definition is a little bit
harder to hit with I usually don't go
one-on-one with Widowmaker because she
almost always has the drop and she
doesn't have that travel time with her
bullets she also can see much farther he
doesn't he has a slight zoom but it's
not an actual scope so I would avoid
that but other than that if you can take
out anybody at a range besides
Widowmaker I would say almost anybody
he's one of those very elusive counters
to Bastion that we all talk about but
nobody ever really knows how always do
is charge a beer arrow pop around a
corner hit bash in about three times and
you'll take him out and the rest of team
will love you and they won't be pissed
when Bastion gets the plate again done
and dusted thanks so much Mike and for
more overwatch hero guides stay tuned to
games for calm